hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome back to let's play The
Crooked Man okay so we're in a weird Oh
the door opens now was it the monster
that locked it okay so we're in this
weird Hospital again and we still need
to find a bunch of things and I didn't
check the rooms over here oh this is
slightly different hang on a minute wait
there's something different over here
all the this isn't a surgery room
anymore there's an examination table or
some radiation treatment table hang on
it's got to be something here worth
getting that's I there's got to be a
reason for these rooms I mean they don't
have just empty rooms anywhere there's
got to be a reason Lauren my own anyway
hello hello oh come on please please
please ah
okay maybe not maybe I am wrong but then
again I wait what three digit code seems
to lead to the emergency stairs eh mmm
how interesting okay so this was all
painted over that Ed the human fetus
okay so I need to go up one more floor
there we go okay hello Scott from a
notebook my mother told me I was born
here she called it a place of happiness
but for me it is a place of regret I
wish I could kill my child self back
when I was pure when I still thought
everyone loved me that's pretty cruel so
we seem to be going over a few phases
here in the hotel the notes were about
the girlfriend in the school the notes
were about himself and then in here the
Scott the notes are about a child in
which I have a child with me here ah
come on
these rooms are different too gosh damn
there's got to be a reason there needs
to be a reason what is the reason
come on I'm just gonna sit here and make
me your nose until I finally find I need
five I've checked everything in these
rooms there is nothing in here nope nope
nope nope don't don't don't
dawn oh nothing nothing I don't care
anymore that's stupid emergency stairs
and blah blah blah there's an entrance
to the emergency stairs on the third
floor that needs a six digit PIN but I
still don't have anything that is gonna
help me so I am at a loss as far as that
goes I'm summing in the comments section
said I missed the flowers which were
where exactly I'm not exactly sure maybe
there's a victim I know see any flowers
I just see a creepy baby okay maybe it's
on the first floor maybe I'm wrong maybe
I'm wrong flowers No well alright then
now it flowers there we go alright so we
got that now the rest of the clues said
what do they say exactly the rest of the
clues said flowers good wash your hands
where do you have lunch so I need to go
to the cafeteria I already got the phone
one a nurses know that so probably
something in the nurse's station and
then get close to the sky which I'm
assuming means the top floor so I can go
back to the way wolves over here
nothing emergency patient transport that
doesn't work and that doesn't work okay
why even have these robes ok nurses
station
nurse nurse are they here nurse it might
be something in one of the other lockers
nothing left nothing left nothing left
this box has nothing left this box has
nothing left
oh look inside
got an eyepiece is this gonna spell
AEIOU and sometimes why okay what was
the other one
um cafeteria that's right okay go into
the cafeteria
come on long little fluffy if I could
hear my target actually go where I want
to go come along little really fun my
name is now Billy its fluffy
no its Billy now a empty can empty can
those are where that's where the wire
came from dirty teacup oh yes
all right I'm actually making some
progress I only need one left which is
get close to the sky so to the top floor
on here this area of the hospital or
it's in the other area over there get
close to the sky ah that wind whistling
is getting disconcerting it seems like a
haunted choir more than anything hello
okay nothing left in there no no no no
no aah man oh oh no what the hell I see
them they're not going away
wha huh uh huh I just saw a shadow what
is my imagination what's up mr. Jamie
it's nothing Billy my name is fluffy too
bad magazines about mental health that's
a good sign
okay there's got to be something in here
that's necessary
these have something loan diary tape 15
subdue visitor a garret guarantor for
relative in room 413 a visited a visited
after sudden change in patient's
condition patient was hospitalized upon
identified brain illness surgery deemed
unnecessary due to declining health the
patient tortures a daily due to still
thinking herself healthy
her memories of a are also vague a
sought counseling on how to cope the
patient misunderstands it as a
abandoning her she cries and scream her
mine unstable counseling will likely
continue for both visitor a:visited
after the patient's death he lamented
that given she was going to die he could
watch over her at home wait a minute
this is what David was talking about
early in the game he stated that living
in itself is not happy so if your life
is agony then wanting death is
unavoidable should I refuse him as a
doctor tolerated as a person of dignity
I wish he would come back here but
unfortunately I can't force him I wonder
if this thing kind of things happens a
lot what's that a storybook no it's not
key to the psychiatric ward I think wait
what small I got a small key to nowhere
is that the key that I just used has a
psychiatry tag so there must be
something in here was there wait no this
is where the this is where this was
there's nothing in there
wait a minute wait a minute wait a
minute wait a minute
door seems to be busted I don't recall
any locked door in here I think these
are all patients from anyway so I'm
guessing that there must be a door maybe
one of these uh these okay so nothing
there I'm guessing it must be in the
other wing or either in the third floor
here but no this is why I found fluffy
wait no that I already been to the
cafeteria never mind that's right okay
so if I go downstairs and across the way
down here to this long hallway I should
be able to find what I need
but then again I might be wrong lately
I've been talking a lot so my voice has
gotten a bigger rumble No
know what was in the basement I'm
thinking this oh there was a crooked man
don't fluffy don't go crazy on me and he
walked a crooked mile he found a crooked
sixpence upon a crooked stile he bought
a crooked cat which caught a crooked
Mouse and they all live together in a
little crooked house there was a crooked
man huh shut the [ __ ] up fluffy
yeah mama taught it to me I like to sing
so I sing lots and I like that song ah
what is it mister I actually learned it
as a kid too but I didn't like it very
much why not it just felt like a sad
song to me the guy's been crooked his
whole life and all he's got around him
is cooking stuff I was scared to think
what if I was a crooked man only when I
was a kid of course I don't get it mr.
butt sorry for singing it's sad song and
no it just reminded me of that you're a
good singer fluffy do you sing with your
momma yeah momma likes this thing too
it's fun to sing with her do you sing
too David haha
no I'm no good you're better off not
hearing me try but you can hear me try
in my new channel markiplier sings where
I sing non-stop all day long every day
all day every day come on by oh there's
nothing down here it's locked medicine
room okay so I need a key to the
medicine room and I need to find the
psychiatric ward there anything in here
oh there's anything in here no no this
is where I found fluffy again
okay keyhole painted over keyhole
painted over nothing over here correct
correct
so here nothing odd about it
gosh cans empty okay there was nothing
in here bulletin board no I've been
through all these before and the
emergency stairs are over there so I'm
just gonna assume that it's not
necessary
keyhole painted over
gasps room he all painted over well gosh
dang it son of a monkey what though I am
I am not happy I'm not happy I'm not
happy ah got it
oh oh hey you better run that was a
Hanged Man I may have mentioned it
before what bed trash board wait those
are long rugs but perhaps I check those
I checked those a million times what
what are the numbers for I know what the
numbers are for you dick I know what
they're for John Smith is dead he hung
himself I was no help at all it seems I
took a look at the note under his feet
and it said this it's chasing me no
matter where I go I can't ever escape so
I've decided to die
but I realized it's grinning in fact
it's grinning behind me right now
it's been waiting for me to do this this
is what is was chasing me for but now
I'll be free from it doctor please take
care it might turn to follow you next
there's no point in running because it's
always it's someone's back goodbye thank
you for everything doctor you were the
only one who had sympathy yeah about
that
okay so it's um this is dumb but
whatever so I need to go that I'm on the
fourth floor I'll go the bottom one on
the board third one in the trashcan
second one on the bed why do I have to
check a clue to be able to find
something I went through all the time of
finding every single thing looking at
every single thing in those rooms but no
no it has to be a giant douche about it
let's see tear it off
screw it there's a number on the board
six good good good everyone remember
that put it in your brains six and on
the third floor it was in the middle on
the bread was it no maybe was in the
trash I don't know where it was maybe
what's in here
question ah her number one okay so we
got a 6 and a 1 or a 1 and a 6 I'm not
sure which it is but I'll find out soon
enough
just like I doubt everything and it was
in the middle on the bed nothing odd
about it
turn that [ __ ] over look under 7 ok 7
1 6 those are three numbers and as we
already know there's a three number
thingy on the third floor at the end of
the hallway to the emergency stairs with
which I will be able to go awesome can't
wait can't wait 7 1 6 or 6 1 7
nope 7 1 6 ok yes yes
what oh hi hello sky beep give me shut
up
ok anyway back to the game sorry about
that that's a huge pile sandbags here
you can't go down if you say so
ok went up no that leads outside again
go up ah I'm gonna reach the sky and
then I'm gonna ah large wire not even
pliers could cut this um I could
probably cut it with wives not that I
have any of those what can I do about
this good question
dick
that's where the last piece isn't it try
to touch the sky that's what it said so
I need to find something that can break
that wire now if I was thinking I was
thinking huge pile stand back so I came
Oh what was the point of that ah there
was no point hello
bye okay alright then okay what the hell
god dammit what ah god damn you game god
damn you so hard ah what okay there's
still this safe here right I haven't
opened the safe yet locked I don't have
a key for it um oh okay so if I was in a
hospital and plyers can't cut it that
means they probably want some sort of
acid which means that I need to find
some sort of acid cabinet is locked
haha ah give me acid yeah the key to the
medicine room ah well not as good but
where was the medicine was it on this
same area no who's downstairs it was
downstairs that was right that was right
don't get downstairs okay
unlock the door open it here ah looks
like a great many chemicals in here the
noose the newbie Steve made a fine mess
he spilled some hydrogen bromide and
made a hole in the wall I told him that
stuff could he threw iron he'd better
pay me back for this hydrogen bromide
you say ha ha ha ha see maybe I have to
synthesize it myself
tripped and all see estrogen progestin
Oh what are they for um guess buddy
zinc Oh ere we go hydrogen bromide err
kid hole this bottle of hydrogen bromide
for me I just go skipping around long
the hallways
lotty fricken da just have a great time
okay let me go back to the third floor
and then move along the way I have to
say I don't know if I'm getting close to
the ending but I know there's still a
lot of stuff left to do I still got to
get all one last letter and then put it
wherever the hell that's supposed to go
yes go to the hydrogen bromide oh come
on just use it you know you're supposed
to coughing stand back this could be
dangerous not me though
what bad ass reminds me of SAS science
equipment whoosh the door can be open
now I'll open it we're outside of fluffy
Rhian I can't see mama from here she
must still be looking for that thing she
lost I hope she comes find me soon
she'll be here soon I'm sure you love
your love your mama ha fluffy yeah
Mama's the best do you like your mama
mr. David
yeah I gotta love my mama I mean my
mother family is important my mama's
nice but she's scary when she's mad is
your mama nice yeah I'm home are you
feeling better mom did you go to the
hospital
welcome home Davey it's just a cold
don't blow it out of proportion
I feel a lot better after getting some
rest there's really no good side to
being feeble I'm sorry to always be
causing you trouble don't worry about it
mom we're just a family of two of course
we have to help each other
ho ho you're so kind say how is it going
with Shirley she hasn't come by here
lately we haven't met much because of
work though I'd like to talk with her
more about the future and all that she
must be anxious it's a big event in a
woman's life make sure to support her
will you what event are you sure you're
not in pain mom you don't look very well
get some sleep I can make my own meal
glad to have such a kind Sun Thank You
Davy what big event in a woman's life
yes she's always very kind to me she's
always cared about me
haha you better get home soon then mr.
David your mama must be really worried I
suppose you're right same reason why
yours will show up soon so just weigh
with me until then yeah all right
whatever you say okay is this where the
last pieces allow psychiatrist at local
hospital commit suicide
early this morning a doctor employed at
the General Hospital was found dead by a
nurse from the same hospital he was
hanged so police are deeming it a
suicide if you say so wait a minute
where's the piece okay no maybe no
somewhere else to the sky to the sky
okay climb up need to go a little bit
higher ah I didn't even see anything on
the ground there I just click cuz I'm a
badass apparently go go down come on man
what's this panel to the side here ok
nothing can I leave now I don't get out
of here
wait a minute once it's done bag shuts
wait what what what what's going on oh
there we go ok so I finally got that
piece and I'm very close to the end of
this I believe I'm not sure either the
hospital part I don't know if there's
gonna be another more but it seems like
it's all gonna end here I don't know
though so anyway thank you all so much
for watching click the annotation for
more videos that I've done and as always
I will see you in the next video
bye-bye
one
God
shut up